en medio de la crisis social derivada de
la Reforma del sistema de la
jubilaciones en Francia el gobierno de
Manuel macrón presentó hoy en consejo de
ministros otro proyecto de ley polémico
y también emblemático de su
administración el segundo el primero fue
presentado en su primer quinquenio nos
referimos a la ley de inmigraciones el
21 texto relativo a esta materia desde
1986 en Francia el gobierno dice que
quiere facilitar la regularización de
los migrantes a través del trabajo de
hecho el año pasado esa regularizaciones
aumentaron en un 45% para eso va a crear
un permiso de residencia profesión u
oficio en tensión justamente para
postular los migrantes tienen que llevar
más de tres años en Francia de manera
irregular ejercer uno de esos oficios
donde falta mano de obra hoy y presentar
ocho nóminas de trabajo la lista de esos
oficios todavía no ha sido publicada
pero se habla de la construcción la
restauración sin embargo la oficina de
empleo francesa Polo publica cada año
una lista de aquellas profesiones donde
falta mano de obra y en primer lugar en
la última lista aparecía la limpieza la
ayuda a la persona y los enfermeros y
enfermeras el gobierno también pretende
crear un permiso de residencia para
talentos personas que ejercen alguna
profesión en el área sobre todo de la
medicina y de la salud también se
compromete el gobierno con este proyecto
de ley a expulsar a los migrantes que
tienen a problemas con la ley en Francia
que han cometido delitos ya aquellos a
quienes se les ha rechazado el pedido de
asilo también a acelerar justamente el
análisis de las demandas de asilo y
refugio político la derecha se opone a
este proyecto dice que ese nuevo permiso
de trabajo va a generar un efecto
llamada a la izquierda dice que es otro
texto aún más restrictivo y las
organizaciones que trabajan con los
migrantes se oponen también dicen que no
es necesario otro permiso de trabajo que
los que ya existen son bastante
complicados y muy burocráticos que
exigen muchos y que difieren de
prefectura en prefectura que son las que
analizan justamente las demandas de
residencia dicen que este nuevo título
se prestará aún más para la
arbitrariedad de los funcionarios ellos
exigen simplemente que se regulariza a
todas las personas que se encuentran sin
documentación en Francia para ir más
lejos el ministro del interior de Manuel
macrosd ha dicho que incluso podría
crear cuotas de migración como alguna
vez lo pensó Nicolás arcosí un guiño a
la derecha y a la extrema derecha dice
los críticos del gobierno